let's go to our next caller from the
eight one eight area code caller from
eight one eight tell us tell us who you
are and what's on your mind hey Jesse
from Los Angeles how you doing huh good
go ahead Jesse hey so I live out here in
LA and the michael moore fahrenheit
eleven nine failed they bombed at the
box office
yep it uh made like three million
dollars and i saw it over the weekend
and i was what if i can do a quick
little film review for you to kind of
maybe encourage people to go see it i
don't know your views on michael moore
but i think that the film was marketed
and properly as as a trump film Brian
it's really not a movie about Donald
Trump
okay I'm which was pretty surprising and
I don't know if you saw it or not no I
didn't but it's really just yields about
how we got here really focuses call emic
thirty like a third of the film about
Flint water crisis a third of the film
is about fascism and the Germany in the
1930s and how it relates to you know
modern-day trumpism and how Democrats
centrism by Democrats has kind of
enabled the rise of the hard right
similarly to how in the German in the
1930s centrist
enabled the rise of the Nazi Party which
was a minority party you know that that
kind of got gained more power by you
know disenfranchising liberals on the
Left yeah you know the thing really
Jesse I don't think that the so I
haven't seen the film and I don't I
don't actually plan to and it's not that
I think that the film is not a good film
it's not that I don't like Michael Moore
I think what it is more is that even
what you're talking about like on the
program we've been talking about the
ways in which Democrats failing to
actually be progressive enables politics
to move to the right we've talked about
flint we've talked about all these
issues it's more just that I feel that
we've been having overload of these
issues now for two years under trumpism
and flint has been going on for so long
at this point it's more that I feel that
I'm unsure that given the limited time I
have and the in frequency with which I
go and see movies then I'm gonna go and
watch that one is more what it is it's
not
anything critical about the film itself
you know right I think that's actually
exactly why people didn't go see it
because I think our life is like a
24-hour Trump film yeah so you know I
think that's a big part of it but if
you're looking for sort of encouragement
it does break down the facts of how
America is actually a leftist country
and it gives you all the facts behind
that and I think if yours it's a dark
film it is a hit kind of a horror story
but it's not all about Trump if you're
if that's what you were expecting so if
people are sort of looking for some
encouragement about what who our country
actually is it's just it just encourages
us to vote and actually likes plays in a
tomorrow you know participate in a
democracy so hey Jesse anyway where are
you calling from it's I'm curious where
you are it sounds extraordinarily
exciting I'm actually at LAX right now
oh you're at LAX Airport yeah yeah all
right no no problem no I appreciate the
call it's good to hear this perspective
because we I've been hearing mostly
negative things about the film and all
right Jesse thanks for the call have a
good flight
yeah take care okay take care